this is an unnecessarily rushed
explanation of the most disturbing game
of all time
hotline Miami how in Miami really tricks
you into thinking it's gonna be kind of
cute because it has this indie game sort
of pixel aesthetic and it looks like
you're gonna play Smash TV or something
like that and it's gonna be I mean to
actually be obviously it was violent you
shot a lot of people but you know it was
all fun
so hotline Miami kind of looks like it's
about the same thing over and over as
you compliment the old grand theft
auto's nothing you read that dollars so
you walk into a house and there's a
whole bunch of guys in there and you've
got to murder them all you got a
baseball bat and him on the head if they
have a gun him on the bat take your gun
go into the next room the problem is the
controls are really kind of very quick
and fluid and floaty and so there's a
possibility that you're gonna bust into
this room full of guys and what's gonna
happen is you're gonna do a full pulp
fiction thing where the guy comes out of
the kitchen means like die die die die
die die die and then none of the bullets
hit and then you get creamed so
basically what by the time you're ready
to go into one of these rooms especially
if you're already sort of at the end of
the level and like everything's on the
line you have to do the whole level over
again scrub you know your heart is
pounding pounding pounding really fast
because like you really feel like you're
in this livered I've had a situation
that we actually are able to kill all
the dudes in the room you feel like this
you know sense of euphoria but then that
you have this whole sort of crazy climb
down at the end of it because what
happens is you know after you kill this
whole house full of people
you have to like leave the house
particularly and climb over all their
corpses and walk over all the blood look
at all the damage that you did it was
kind of really disturbing and then then
it can even more disturbing because the
entire thing feels like this crazy
hope-filled drug trip because the game
the level is like rotating and it's
rotating back and forth and it makes you
feel like you're very dizzy and then
there's this sort of garish neon pink
glow colors being pumped into your
eyeballs like you're in Las Vegas and
you just did too many drugs and passed
out middle street and and there's techno
music playing and it's all very
disturbing and it really just makes you
want to you know finish your level eyes
then just go down walk away and have a
nice cup of herbal tea and forget all
about it but the game is so addicted
that you want to play more
more and more and more